- So, there is this app that's
a trivia game called HQ.
I'm sure you guys have played it.
Everyone's talking about it.
I actually haven't played it yet.
But someone just told me that
you can win money playing HQ.
I like money, so I thought, you know what?
I'm gonna download, but
I'm not just gonna try it.
I'm gonna win it, but I'm
not just gonna win it.
I'm gonna master it, but
I'm not just gonna master--
Yeah, the joke was over
about a minute ago.
Let's go play some HQ.
(intense music)
All right, so I just downloaded HQ.
I'm actually pretty nervous.
I really hope that this video
is just like one minute long.
It's my into and then just
me mastering it immediately.
This is weird.
The app is very like old school.
And there's just comments nonstop.
Scott, Scotty, Scott.
So, I have three minutes
'til the game starts.
And I guess I'll just take this time
to kind of prepare, a little training.
Two plus two equals four.
Finish this sentence,
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse.
List the presidents in order.
George Washington.
(gentle music)
All right, the game started.
720,000 people playing.
I can beat 720,000 people easy.
- [Host] $2,000!
Question one, which of these creatures
is most likely to bark?
Mime, did you bark up the
right tree, and pick dog?
Which of these things is
not found inside an atom?
Proton, wonton?
The answer is wonton.
Which of these is not the
title of a current TV show?
Chicago Med, Chicago
Fire, or Chicago Police?
Chicago Police.
- No!
Chicago PD, that's a show.
PD means police, right?
(gentle music)
I'm so upset, I could have easily won.
Let me see.
- [Host] Who was not a wife of Henry VIII?
Catherine Parr?
- Catherine Howard.
How I am supposed to know this stuff?
Catherine Howard sounds
like a friend of my mom's.
- [Eric Voiceover] Even
though I was frustrated,
I kept playing.
I had hope that I could win this game,
and I played every chance I got.
Only problem was that I kept losing.
(gentle music)
Over, and over again.
But then, I got an idea.
- I'm just gonna go around the office,
see who knows HQ best,
and see if they wanna join my HQ team.
Do you know HQ?
- Headquarters?
- No, not headquarters, the game HQ.
- No, I'm actually not familiar with it.
- Do you know what HQ is?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah?
(laughs)
- I'm trying to make a team.
So, that we can win every single time.
- Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
That's a fantastic idea.
- So, do you guys like split
the five dollar earnings if you win?
- [Cameraman] How well
thought out is this team?
- Not at all.
Which of these cities was never
a capital of the Persian empire?
Oh, I can't pronounce any of these.
(all laugh)
Nineveh, Baghdad, Pasar-ga-driah.
Okay, skip this question,
'cause I can't pronounce it.
Which TV show was rebooted as a sequel,
but with new actors as
the same characters?
MacGyver (laughing).
Which of these snacks was founded
in Finland dating back
to around 6,000 B.C?
Potato chips, chewing gum, cheese sticks.
- (grunting) Cheese sticks.
- Dave my man.
- Did I get it?
- No.
- Wait a second, you're
not Scott, get outta here.
- Actress Emma Watson
studied at which University?
Harvard, Brown, or Cambridge?
- Brown.
- You are correct.
Sarah, you know what?
Four for four, that's good enough,
I think you've made the team.
- Those were just, oh,
I want more questions.
- [Cameraman] We have more questions,
I feel like you're not
doing this very well.
- No, but I just, I'm sick
of trying to find this team,
so I'm just gonna accept four.
- [Cameraman] So it's just
gonna be you and Sarah?
- No, no, no, I mean so far yes.
- [Cameraman] That's not a team.
- [Eric Voiceover] My cameraman was right.
I had to step up my game, I had to talk to
everyone in the office and
form the ultimate HQ team.
(intense music)
That's what I did.
We were confident.
Yeah we were, we were a little too conf--
We were really confident.
(upbeat funky music)
- [Host] How many US state names
are only four letters long?
- That's such a hard question,
if we all get out on two right now.
(all laughing)
- [Group] Iowa, Iowa...
- Clearly it's three,
we can't be that bad.
(all laughing)
(all cheering)
- [Guy] It's between two and three.
- Yes, yes, no, it's the oboe.
- Woo
- Not gonna toot my oboe.
- Oh, snap, snap, snap.
- [Eric Voiceover] We were doing so well,
I thought we were all gonna
win, until this one question.
- [Guy] What, what's a glabella?
- [Girl] I'm gonna say Phelps,
I don't know what that means.
- [Guy] Dammit.
(all yelling)
- [Eric] Everyone's out.
- Oh, I'm in!
(all cheering)
- [Eric Voiceover] We made
it to the final round.
(all cheering)
(intense music)
- [Guy] Bradley Cooper, Bradley Cooper.
- That's such an easy question.
- [Eric Voiceover] It
was an easy question.
And so we won.
(all cheering)
But I wasn't satisfied, because
I wasn't the one who won,
and that's what I set
out to do in this video.
So there was more work to be done.
- So I'm gonna talk to some
of the best HQ players,
and see what advice they have.
- Hi, I'm Jamie Ortiz.
I'm the HQ trivia winner for $6,000.00.
- What?
Wait, I didn't know that,
are you the top winner?
- There's another guy named Casey Donahue.
- I'm Casey Donahue, I'm one of the
all time winners on HQ trivia.
- Hey I'm Zach Kornfeld,
I work at Buzzfeed.
I'm one of the Try Guys,
and I'm also an Hqtie.
What you might not know about me,
is that I'm a four time HQ champion.
- I've been playing HQ
for like two weeks now
and I have had no luck,
do you have any advice?
How do I win this game?
- I'm not gonna lie and pretend
that I have won all by myself.
You're playing with your friends,
you only have three seconds to Google.
But can you Google something that
points you in the right direction.
- Definitely go with your gut.
- The night I won, I
played a little more loose,
wasn't overthinking
it, and I think you are
in the right mindset to win the game.
- Honestly from the richest HQ player,
coming from you, I
think I'm gonna win now.
(game show music)
- [Eric Voiceover] I was so nervous
while playing the game that
I actually forgot to talk.
I just wanted to focus on the
questions and the answers.
And that's what I did, and
I answered a lot right,
so many actually, that I
made it to the 12th question.
It was the most stressful
moment in my life.
This meant so much to me, I mean
not really but it did, sort of.
- [Host] He does not
mention Grand Master Flash
and that is your answer baby.
- Oh my God!
Oh my God, there is no one in the office
for me to share this with.
$34.00, I won. (upbeat playful music)
I'm an HQ master, Mom.
- [Eric's Mom] What?
- I won HQ.
- [Eric's Mom] No way, you're lying.
- It's that unbelievable,
for me to win HQ?
- [Eric's Mom] Yes.
- Anyway, lesson learned,
Google helps a lot.
Having a group of people,
like you know 20 people
texting what they think
the answer is really helps.
But sometimes you have to trust
yourself and not trust them.
The game's fun, Eric approved, I love it.
(fun upbeat music)